[Music]
[Applause]
chris sims has his uh quarterback list
out we always look forward to this it's
kind of christmas in june and that
brings us with chris do you see what i
did with that chris muss
okay
oh
wow i saw what you did i've heard better
from you that's why i mean you got to
earn it you got to earn it okay
chris christmas okay chris
sims pro football talk live co-host
former nfl quarterback let me start at
the top it used to be
at least it felt like this mahomes
and then it was everybody else
that's not the case anymore but it's not
like mahomes has fallen that far the
number one quarterback in the nfl right
now is
is josh allen of the buffalo bills okay
you know and then mahomes again we're
this is he's great we know that i'd
almost want to say josh allen is one and
mahomes is 1a that's what kind of guys
they are they're super talented the two
of the most physically gifted
quarterbacks we've ever seen in football
already at this point of their careers
are special that way but yes josh allen
for me right now is the best quarterback
in football dan you know one the
physical talent i mean it's arguably the
strongest arm in football right there
with mahomes and justin herbert you know
he can throw it all crazy different ways
sidearm whatever body being in weird
positions and then the other thing too
is he he's the best runner in football
as well not named lamar jackson other
than lamar jackson josh allen is the
best running quarterback in the league
so i think you add that in and then he's
a good decision maker and can play the
position from a traditional standpoint
at a very high level and to me dan that
was where he separated from my homes a
little bit in this year's rankings
mahomes as you know and anybody that
watched football this year you know he
did not play his best football he was
inconsistent in the pocket he got he
walked himself into a lot of sacks and
pressures and he was just a little too
aggressive and greedy in decision making
as we discussed during the season a few
times but just looking for the big play
a little too much but which led to some
problems with their offense yeah josh
allen in the playoffs 14 touchdowns one
interception
i didn't know if justin herbert was
actually going to slip by patrick
mahomes i
for some reason i thought you might toy
with that idea of justin herbert second
best quarterback in the nfl or joe
burrow
they're they're there they're there
they're they're on the cusp i will say i
think allen and mahomes are in a little
bit of a class of their own
but like herbert and burrow they're like
they're knocking on the door a little
bit like hey let me see in there i think
we're we can do we can be in that room
too there's no question herbert it's
just it's it's just the throwing is off
the off the charts good you know for his
size what he does you know the amount of
throws when there's a clean pocket i
don't know if there's a better thrower
of the football in the whole league than
justin herbert in every which way
possible and then you know
these top four guys the other thing i
love about their game and to me why they
surpassed aaron rodgers is they're
capable of doing more and being a little
bit more aggressive with decision making
and kind of putting their foot on their
throat on your throat when that time is
there to be had and that to me was the
special part about justin herbert his
size is a real skill his ability to
throw over people and people around him
in the pocket is phenomenal he like
burrow a great decision maker as well i
think he could play a little bit more
backyard football he's a
too good of an athlete to stand there in
the pocket all the time the way he does
but dan i mean you're not off his talent
and and everything is up there in that
conversation but it feels like you're
holding the post season against aaron
rodgers
and that's fair if you did yeah but you
have rogers the fifth best quarterback
in the nfl right and and i i did not go
into this exercise thinking he would be
number five i never go in with
preconceived thoughts you know i really
went into it and thought like when i
wrote my first little list down without
going into studying of guys yet i had
rogers at three i thought oh he'll be
three but then as i started to go
through the year with some of these guys
i realized what i saw in the playoffs
from rogers actually happened a lot
during the year they just they squeaked
by and won the games fortunately a few
times even though he kind of did the
same thing you go back to the ravens
game the browns game some other games
that they barely won in the fourth
quarter where they had comfortable leads
and were controlling the game but too
conservative not taking advantage of
some plays that are there to be had to
put the game away and all of a sudden
you're in a nail biter and to me
joe burrow justin herbert would never go
down the way aaron rodgers went down in
that playoff game so the playoff game
was really a microcosm of some things
that went on during the year it's just
they were good enough to kind of
overcome that and they didn't have to
play a team like the 49ers as well which
of course made those those things a
little tougher as well yeah matthew
stafford is the sixth best quarterback
in the nfl
this has to be based off the postseason
because the regular season he led the
nfl in interceptions granted it's only
17 but yeah if if he's not
if he doesn't win the super bowl
is he still sixth on your list
i don't know i mean if they if he if
they don't win the super bowl and he
still plays the way he does i think he's
still yes right there okay you know the
rest of the playoffs were special the
year itself was still damn good but he
did do it he went through a period of
like man is he gonna do a stupid thing
every week here like is this really
gonna happen now you gotta give a little
benefit of the doubt too of learning the
new offense and he was playing injured
and all that but hey i've come on here
what the last few years and we've talked
about this list and he's been in the top
ten and people always question that and
the thing i love about stafford is
people don't question it now now you saw
what he can do when he's with the team
and i think it will only get better the
interception thing is interesting dan
too you know burro herbert they were up
there in the league leaders and
interceptions but you know what i've
came away with through this year of
studying a little bit is
you know i i err on the guy throw
double-digit interceptions you're
scarier as a quarterback you're better
as a quarterback when you're more
aggressive even the way brady played
this year brady going down swinging he's
throwing lasers and if they lose and he
throws three interceptions so what the
league is set up right now for the
quarterbacks to go win these games and
make big plays and to me that's where
the top four are really special they can
overcome just about anything on their
football team and make it happen chris
sims pro football talk live co-host with
mike florio tom brady eighth on the list
led the league in touchdown passes last
year decided to come back for another
year
why
eight
well he's i you know i don't i look at
it and go then that's amazing i i guess
you know some people look at it and
probably go well that's mean he should
be higher than that i mean he's brady i
think we talked about this a little bit
during the year
he can take advan take advantage of more
with more than maybe any of these
quarterbacks
sure you put him on the best team in
football with a great offensive
coordinator and he's going to make that
team look unbelievable he's going to get
in the right decision the right throw
make plays with his arms all that but my
list is predicated on
one we're all on the same team we all
have the same team and we're on the
offense that's got a little of
everything but you know it's not kyle
shanahan or mcdaniels and giving you
every advantage in the world that way
and then i try to base it off of one
physical ability two smarts right three
leadership effect on the team four how
you work in the pocket those are my main
things brady's arm's phenomenal but
you've heard me say this before if if
the protection is not good and
it it's just average brady can be kind
of average i'm i'm just sorry there's no
way he could do what joe burrow did with
cincinnati and go to the super bowl with
one of the worst offensive lines in the
sport you know so that's where it comes
in you can do more with more but i would
say he can't do more with less like some
of those other guys as phenomenal as he
is that's the one issue he has in his
game right now at this point of his
career you have russell wilson seven
brady eight dak prescott is nine
lamar jackson is 10. oh yeah that was a
tough one
what does dak prescott well he throws
better than lamar but yeah as far as an
impact
on their team lamar means more to the
ravens than dak does to the cowboys it
feels like i i don't disagree with you
there lamar might have them one of the
most biggest effects out of anybody on
their football team as far as just
belief leader in the locker room
everybody loves them they want to be a
part of lamar's life that's where he's
special but i think you kind of said it
you know one yeah lamar had a down year
16 touchdowns 13 interceptions and
his arm is great he can throw the ball a
bunch of different ways like allen
mahomes he's amazing sidearms awkward
angles doing all that stuff but last
year he was just too reckless i think
that was the biggest thing i came to
just too much trying to make a big play
squeeze a ball into the right window
wait this guy's open for 10 yards why
are we trying to force the ball 30 yards
down the sideline into double coverage
he got a little too loose with decision
making throwing the football last year
and you know prescott even though it
wasn't his best year yeah i think
ultimately played better you know with
not a great defense not much of a run
game and then and again you know you say
the importance of lamar i get that but
dallas is
they're they're predicated on on dak
prescott too it is him and you got to
throw for 400 yards and three touchdowns
or i'm not sure we can win the game so i
don't think he gets quite the credit he
deserves sometimes for dak prescott for
the franchise quarterback he is would
you give the full boat
uh to lamar jackson or kyler murray
the max
oh
i'd be scared i would be scared a little
bit
with with with lamar just in the point
of we're at a point in your career
where
you know i do think he lost a half a
step last year he doesn't have three
rockets up his butt anymore it's just
two and a half rockets up his butt how
about the stop sign
for the max right franchise
or let him go
i would sign from the max if he gave me
those options kyler murray same way
yes i am again you know kyler murray i
got to see another year i i hear you
there's questions certainly and and as i
tell foreo all the time there's a huge
faction in the league that would never
have kyler murray be their starting
quarterback they just think he's too
small and he can't make enough plays in
a crowded pocket and people are
collapsing that way and that's a big
question i'm with you but he's still
special he's not the kind of guy you
know you just sell or throw overboard to
go well i think we can get somebody else
and the the two the one thing that both
of these guys have in their favor dan
is the organizations have kind of gone
all in on them and they've made an
offense that really like fits them and
not very many people and to me that's
kind of where they have a little bit
more power in this situation than than
most
you got deshawn watson the 13th best
quarterback what are you basing that off
of yeah that's another one that's
it's tough i mean
i know when deshaun watson's playing and
all systems go he's in the top five
quarterback conversation i get that but
i mean we've gone a year without playing
football a year and a half without
really practicing football until just
here recently with some otas i can't
think that he's just gonna come back and
hit the ground running and we're gonna
be like oh man look at him he's one of
the best in the game right now i gotta
think there's gonna be a little bit of a
wait let me get back and get used to
things a little here and then i don't
know maybe the the fact that i really
don't expect him to be playing football
this year kind of maybe made me a little
biased with that a little but he was
again another guy that was very tough to
place in this list you have ryan
tannehill in there at 15.
yeah can he win a game in the playoffs
with his arm
he can he definitely can last year and
he fell a few spots yeah well yeah he
can i mean he's he's you know they beat
the ravens a few years ago i know there
weren't big yards but he made like two
or three big time throws in baltimore to
win that game and and get them there you
know so there there is you know that
element you know
now is he gonna win the game with his
right arm to the capacity of like i
think what you're talking about like joe
burrow or mahomes or josh allen no
that's that's not then that's why he's
15. those guys are special you just go
all in with those guys and go give them
the ball every play and let them make it
happen no you gotta tannehill is smart
can do it all but is he the guy that you
want to just go let's play through him
and let him just you know
run the show no no not at all and i
think last year a little too he lost
sight of the team they were and just
took too many chances played defense
controlled the ball and just a
splattering of big plays and you're
going to be tough to beat and in that
playoff game he took things into his own
hands and that bit him in the butt
i would be nervous if i'm an eagles fan
because you have daniel jones zack
wilson justin fields jimmy garoppolo
carson wentz baker mayfield mac jones
they're all ahead of jalen hurts are the
eagles going to look back and regret
this that they didn't make a
quarterbacking change with all of the
talent that they have on that team i
think that
they want to make it work with jalen
hurts
they have questions about him they can
say what they want and they'll continue
to say positive things and they should i
get that there's work that's got to be
done there
but you know you know there's a reason
we heard them in some of the quarterback
rumors and pursuing teams that way
there's an issue with his game they have
a great team i mean it's a team that
again you look at it and you go man
there's not a spot on the roster right
now where you don't go whoa that's kind
of top notch
and you know their offensive line it's
the best in football so that helps out
jalen hurts i know he can run he's a
great leader you know he's pretty smart
and that's how he reads the field and
all that but the throwing is below
average
standards for an nfl quarterback it is
plain and simple and there it's gonna
look okay dan against the middle class
and the poor of the nfl it's just what's
it gonna look like again when we get to
some of the top tier defenses in the
game that we saw last year and then it
becomes whoa
man we don't really have much of a drop
back pass game element and yes i i'm one
that sits there and goes yeah if eagles
who had trevor lawrence or zack wilson
or one of those guys as their
quarterback the eagles fans can say what
they want they would be more excited
about those guys being their quarterback
and they'd be going oh my gosh look at
what we're going to be this year and i
trust them more yes to run again we're
all on the same team a normal offense
and all that stuff that yes i think they
have more talent and they will surpass
jalen hurts this year and everybody will
see that
is this
tua's
last chance in miami
yes
definitely what does he have to do where
you think the dolphins front office is
going to go he's still our our
quarterback right you know it's funny
because hurts it's it's almost the same
thing it's almost the the you know the
intended like wait you have so much
talent here there's we're going to know
what how good you are we would rather
have who would you rather have
man that is a really good question there
gosh
well i mean i do i guess what i'm saying
here with my rankings i think jalen
hurts is a little bit better as of right
now i do think that tua might have more
potential though it's just tua he's got
a quick release he's a gifted passer not
a thrower as far as touch and
anticipation and all that i just think
if he can
if they can win
and he can show that you know again you
don't have to dial up some crazy scheme
play for us to get 10 or 15 yard gain
every now and then and i can put the
ball into a tight window and and make
some throws that move the ball that are
you know outside the realm of okay it's
wide open and served up on a silver
platter i think that'll do it but those
are big ifs because he plays small in
the pocket he does not have a big arm
and the other thing that's scary about
tua when you go back and watch he's
horrible in the elements and he plays in
the afc east to where you go every game
is cold windy a little bit of
precipitation he loses control of the
football and that's got to be an area of
an improvement for him down in miami
good stuff as always
thanks man all right you're the man talk
to you soon that's chris sims see you
guys pro football talk live co-host
great show that precedes hours on
peacock with mike florio